le travail en finale
[Applaudissements]
alors
ces contraintes de voix ronde il a fait
écho aux pratiques magnifique mais très
content de te voir et il a bravé toutes
les épreuves pour venir nous voir
dylan je sais que tu es hyper chaud pour
fracasser toute l'équipe je suis chaud
et chaud ah ouais alors à prendre quelqu
un téléphone qui va jouer avec nous pour
la première épreuve la première épreuve
c'est le parcours c'est donc kelly face
à dylan dans laquelle il a indiqué qu'il
est gay
quant à la puce est allemand levait delà
le malaise s'installe ont montré ces
intrus news ça veut dire la lan
quatrième domaine
elles savent apte à contrôler 10 podiums
à marilyn monroe et puis petit papa
chéri le parcours il s'est récemment on
a quelqu'un en ligne qui est à
l'appareil faisait alors oui bonsoir qui
est là teddy oui teddy teddy tu allais
tout est dit dans le calvados j'adore
dérivés madoff le calvados et à
deauville et à deauville frère du tout
pied ou à kaboul parce qu'elle est très
bien là bas
j'adore là bas je me baladais avant
j'avais une meuf ya de ça une quinzaine
d'années on allait là bas en rigoler et
puis un jour allait rester à bâle et
avec un autre mec t'es dit bah si tu
connais la gb merci que 10 27 ans time
of war oui comment elle s'appelle morgan
tu fais quoi dans la vie je suis employé
du bâtiment du bâtiment c'est à dire
tout ce qui est bâtiment maçonnerie
placoplâtre au ba13 tout ce qui compte
le tour les planches et le plancher
d'accord tout ce qui est au braquet
parquet flottant non le bon moi je suis
très content donc tu fais quoi quand
même le sol bêtement du béton ciré
non en fait je fais le coffrage et après
ils me tombent d'accord l'artois en fait
tu fais tout ce qui est au sol quoi
qu'est ce que tu vas y arriver on
s'adresse il est bonne pas bien raison
il a bien raison merci bim bim et je la
dois aller kelly ya recours tu vas bon
allez oui contre audi la n va ton avis
mais dd dit tu vas jouer pour tu vas
jouer pour ouais tu as échoué pour une
barre de son à ton avis qui va plaire le
parcours le plus rapidement kelly ou
dylan est pris il a le vide tôt j'aurais
dit comme toi on va démarrer par dylan
et après kelly le fera d'accord
attention dylan tu vas être chronométrée
est ce que tu connais parcours dit là tu
dois passer lance tu passe en dessous
tac tac tac tac tu vas là tu vas encore
en dessous la poutre et après tu passes
à baie comeau dylan est un aventurier
stade enlève tout ce que tu veux sur ce
ton slip
merci modèle était beau et beauté lan
prochain
attention mondiale le but est prêt
3 2
où là il est très fort
on met la touche finale
[Musique]
récente dylan j'ai presque envie de dire
est ce qu'on a besoin d'eux c'est le jeu
donne quoi va voir ce que ça donne toi
kelly en plus c'est un avantage c'est
qu'avec ta tête tu peux le faire de bout
ça ta main par un auteur qui n'irait dit
est ce que tu es prête
ben ouais attention attention à toi je
crois dans ce lieu à moi la belle
affaire 13 secondes pour faire là dessus
un bateau où elles arrivent à 13
secondes à 13 km du document
c'est terminé merci merci merci merci
merci
c'est pas mal d ilan donc tu fais gagner
une barre de son la neutralité dit
attention deuxième épreuve
c'est l'épreuve de dégustation on voit
des russes et vous allez vous mettre
derrière derrière ses pupitres tous les
deux les chéris je vais appeler jean
michel baylet attention il est très fort
en dégustation exact oui il en a mangé
des trucs dégueulasses attention dès que
je dis top vous lever et vous devez
manger le plus rapidement possible il
faudra manger les trois mais qui vous
seront proposés qu'en tant avant
qu'après autant la langue réapprendre
chen bing bing bing celui qui aura fini
les trois plats le premier gagnera on
exactement ya trois places et on joue
pour un hoverboard du baril sur qui td
je vois que vraiment compter sur
l'équipe de tpm pluie battante surveille
bêta les appels quoi ça c'est quoi un
cric et à l'ascension vers les métaux
non mais attendez attendez ça va jouer
alors attention quand vous êtes égalité
attention à toi vous finissez à la photo
on la connaît merci merci
attention de l'eau va se jouer sur le
scorpion
on va se jouer sur le scorpion photo
alors et par là que ça ce mardi l'ania
doucement encore tous manqués sur
lormont manu mayonnade scorpions de quoi
tu vas manger encore là donc ça se mange
même la queue d'accord très bien parce
que non on a vérifié quand même
[Rires]
en amont car les gens me est très fort
paraît-il que là que ça soit arrivé là
l'ibla que 500 spécialistes cela tout ça
se mange mon oeil oui mais là il me dit
que sa semence c'est juste qu'il est
coupé des plus petits un scorpion cyr
consiste à ce complot font la queue mais
il a bien aux états côté attention tu
avais que vous serez bien attention
attention c'est faire quoi 2
rien
jean michel mr victoire jean-michel
j'attends sa troisième épreuve
c'est l'épreuve du marteau l'épreuve du
marteau vous allez devoir casser des
pilotes avec un marteau le premier qui
cassent c3 pinata gagne le jeu c'est
isabelle morini-bosc contre dylan et
comment attendait alvarez et rula rouge
ou pour un smartphone tue pas mais sur
qui tu es du sujet j'ai une petite idée
quant à eux
allait-il être les plus grands avec l
erythrée je pense alors attention c'est
ça c'est trop attention je ne sais pas
tu chantes tu joues au foot et
d'insurgés
allez c'est parti c'est beau la menace
hauteur je peux pas t vous apportez
votre audi porte la marque hp n'aurait
jamais dû bien répartir les efforts
j'ai perdu c'est faire mousser bon temps
c'est bon c'est permis merci c'était
vraiment de la merde ce jeu merci bravo
cochon on va jouer maintenant avec les
ja il y a trois heures pour dylan et 3a
pour valérie bénaïm le premier qui
trouve ses trois pièces en or remporte
le jeu mais là ils venaient boire de
pouvoir travailler rien
oui je le sors moi merci hein on va
jouer robot pâtissier multifonctions
d'accord attention attentes en deux
secondes pour trouver les pièces en or
n'a pas les mêmes mozart et bien parce
que c'est pas les mêmes c'est pas les
mêmes c'est pas les mêmes trucs
t'inquiète pas c'est rien du tout c'est
quoi ça sert à rien juste une question
oui en vrai est ce que toi tu pourrais
faire pas bien sûr bien sûr m'a dit
attends je regardais non mais faut pas
regarder sans regarder tu devrais le
faire ou pas mais moi je sais ce qui est
dedans il faut que c'est plus facile
non mais non mais écoutons vers bangui
quand animera l'émission c'est parce que
tu voudras mutation attention 3,2
attendu par les urnes et dénis qui l'a
fortement attention
le collège lasalle paquet t'inquiète pas
c'est pas là et c'est un ancien
chroniqueur chroniqueur jégou c'est bon
alors je m'en suis fait ça sans problème
arrête c'est à péter kurer a tort ah
ouais alors à divers arts est inquiète
et parler plus lentement parmi les huit
des gens bien fait là des points s'il a
des pointes et à des points suivants
attention tu as dis mais c'est ben haim
trouvent les trois boules je te rajoute
l'hoverboard hockey gagné bakou toi je
suis là pour ça j'allais cumulé atteint
sur toi badji valérie pacy vallée b
à l'aller face à batoche savard d'état
terry m'a mordu maintenant
d'accord la cua temps
[Musique]
c'était là
je viens ce qui avait là-dedans j'ai
peur je vais faire vas-y vas-y vela
allait s'en vend pas mais je te pousse
je te trouve dans vrai mais de goût mais
qui tu parles allez vas-y vas-y pour moi
je suis derrière cet hiver ils
s'envoient l'arrière a dit cela à
l'arrêt de l'immigration
d'ici là il est là c'était le rêve de
thé barrette
c'était le rêve de venir allez vas-y
vas-y moi j'aime y a des trucs de fou
[Musique]
je te jure que si tu te fais rien je te
ressemble je te jure je vais te rempli
d'eau a dévalé
vas-y vas-y de franco c'est une poule à
me rendre une poule les vélos
saisissez-vous belhaimer valérie butin
meilleur dans sa mère était tombée quand
vous en dit plus fons ça qu'est ce que
c'est bon ça tombe bien c'est pas ton
fils plus longtemps quelque chose là bas
valérie s'est gagnée grâce à toi et à
dylan y gagne en plus leur board on va
faire maintenant
l'épreuve de force l'épreuve de force
entre eux benjamin castaldi est loin de
vous ces dix là devant vous tous lui
qu'on fasse l'épreuve de force
zidane vous avez vous levé je te parie
devoir porter à bout de bras à 106 kg 6
kg d'accord dylan voilà qu'en belgique
mettez-vous à côté de moi après camille
combal arrive juste après attention si
vous mettez comme ça attention 3 2 1 il
ya le permis à gagner
go away quand même la coopérative 6,6 kg
benjamin nous fait pas honte à dos à la
vache et kg au bout de moi s'il fallait
bien ça roule bien pour l'instant ça
roule bien
bravo on a beau droite dylan 23 ans 23
ans du luxembourg
les boutons pourtant tous vrais boutons
bien
bonjour attention attention bras est
pardon pardon au sol et ça c'est
important pour la ménagère est important
pour toutes les personnes âgées qui nous
regarde pas trop mais si tu aimes
attention moi ouais t'as pas dégage
quand j'ai menti sur paso attention
[Applaudissements]
à jouer
c'est bien bâtiment benji d'amour oui
les chéris donc drogue tu n'as pas gagné
le permis de conduire donc puisque tu ne
voulais pas c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle
c'est à dire bah oui pas alors je
voulais pas donc c'est une bonne
nouvelle